A growing web of rail road and sea routes is at the core of
Beijing's foreign policy strategy. From China to Southeast Asia
Central Asia the Middle East Europe and Africa the Belt Road
initiative is a huge global project expanding and integrating
infrastructure networks which President Xi Jinping has called
the project of this century .
Welcome to Mombasa. Traders have been coming to Kenya's oldest
city for centuries. The Arabs the Portuguese the British and
Indians have all tried their hand at making a fortune here.
The latest are the Chinese. We'll explore that grandiose ambitions
asking whether dreams in far off Beijing match those on the
African continent. I'm Rishaad Salamat. This is Belt Road .
China's trade superhighway .
Mombasa is seen as the gateway to East Africa. At least five
landlocked nations including Uganda and Rwanda rely on this port
to get goods in and out. The Mombasa and Nairobi Standard Gauge
Railway or SGI is the nation's biggest infrastructure project
since independence from Britain in 1963 .
Kenya paid three point eight billion dollars.
China arranged the financing and built what is the start of a rail network that
promises to open up the passage of people and goods deep into
the heart of the continent .
Yes. Jack RTS journey to Kenya's capital to five hours down for
more than eight for cargo transported by truck
The Belt Road initiative is I believe a good initiative for for the region .
The railway link from Mombasa to Nairobi.
I have reservations about the price that was paid for the rail link.
However the fact that we have a rail link now is creating immense opportunities
leading to a reduction in supply lead times and so on.
That's what we wish for.
There's nobody else who can compete with the
Chinese investment into infrastructure. However when we look at
it from an African perspective Kenyan perspective investments
coming in to build our infrastructure are very welcome from
wherever they're coming.
With it's American with it´s Chinese or with it's European
Because they need to make us more competitive.
The market is there. But to get connectivity to
get our products out there is a problem. So we hope that to be
afraid that this market can be opened up not only to China but
to all other countries with India. And that's what we're hoping for.
Better transport links are vital if regional expansion is
not to hit the buffers. The IMF forecast that the East Africa
community will see growth of six point two percent in 2019 .
Mombasa Port itself is expanding to meet the challenge.
The equivalent of one point two million 20 foot containers pass
through this port every year. What's more that figure is
expected to grow by 3 to 5 percent per annum .
The business the potential is blindingly obvious.
So far execution has been the source of a litany of complaints.
Sure the containers get to the capital quicker. The trouble starts
when they get there and when the bills arrive.
The government says it's listening and is determined
not to create a very expensive white elephant .
Such in good cause presses roll out billions of labels each year.
People in supermarkets around the world are unwittingly
familiar with some of them.
There are seven cargo trains a day
coming in bringing 150 containers a day into Nairobi from Mombasa.
So that's almost 800 to a thousand containers a day
which for used to get put onto the single lane road from
Mombasa to Nairobi. Tremendous congestion fatalities and so on.
However Kenya has not properly addressed the bottleneck at the
inland container depot in Nairobi and it is heaving with
containers so that congestion within Nairobi is hurting business
- Do you use it.
- Yes we are.
Even though it's more expensive.
It's in fact where you are kind of forced to by the government.
So logistics is always two way right from Mombasa
going all the way to Ruanda. And then of course later on it can
go all the way to West Africa. As we speak today there is no
railway or roadway going through to West Africa and that can be
done very easy to expunge it. However when we talk about
competitive as we are also talking about return logistics going
back from Kigali all the way to Mombasa all the way to China and
we could have a two way logistics becoming competitive.
This is so key for all our countries to have export products and export
into those markets so that we're competitive both ways .
Bidco is East Africa's leading producer of edible oils.
also makes detergents and other consumer products with factories
in Kenya Uganda Tanzania and Madagascar.
It sells into 18 regional countries.
Chairman DeMoss Shah is cautiously optimistic
about the wider impact of Chinese investments.
I think there's no doubt about one thing that China wants to do
much more trade, right?
Whether we call it economic dominance or whatever.
They have a competitive edge today.
Therefore if they are bringing in their industries here to produce here to
sell to the west what it does to Africa is not that it's going
to be ownership is going to be jobs. It creates jobs here
In your grow grab and sustain your number one position.
Does this worry you?
For us as a company because we're not worried
because we don't see these goods that we make here.
We don't see these coming from China. In fact China is a good market for
some of the consumer goods and with its population China, India
both with their populations there will need much more food.
There will need to have a lot more of products.
And that's what Africa can do. So we've got to look at the competitive
advantage for Africa and to find what other products that we can
then export into China using the same Belt Road initiative.
How much do you currently then sell to China or India.
Zero .
This glass half full attitude is often countered by fears that
all this hugely expensive infrastructure is simply a fast track
for China to exploit new markets by leaving African countries
swimming in debt.
There have also been complaints about transparency
for example how China Road and Bridge Corporation
was given the contract to operate the line for 10 years and
there was no tender process .
Beijing's African enterprise is really based on trade and not benevolence.
It's also inextricably linked to the way the
country sees itself in the future. In a political sense and beyond.
Meanwhile for Kenya and its neighbors they see a medium
term locomotive for growth.
But down the track things look a lot more murky.
Some are raising questions about the level of
indebtedness of whether or not it's a win win relationship .
Coming up we have a look at whether it can be that or it will be
a situation where there's only one Victor .
After Mombasa containers end up here in Nairobi.
Now that's not the end of the story.
It's the start of a more profound one .
Opportunities for new markets stretch beyond Kenya's capital
beyond Kenya itself to Tanzania Uganda Ruanda or even Europe .
The question is did it all come at a price that they can afford
Welcome back to Belt Road. China's trade superhighway.
I'm Rishaad Salamat .
Our leaders are letting Africa go to China. That's my view .
I think we need to do it in moderation
while at the same time maintain our country .
We there's quite a lot we can learn and gain from China quite a lot.
But I think we need to be to some extent not get China to
come and take over our country .
We do not interfere in the internal
affairs of African countries impose our will on African
countries attach any political condition on the economic aid to
Africa nor do we seek selfish political gains was that the
investments and financing cooperation with Africa
China is pushing back against criticism the Belt and Road
Initiative loads up partner countries with debt.
It also refutes claims it's aimed at strengthening Beijing's global influence .
The Chinese president maintains the initiative is a tool for common prosperity.
While roads rail and port infrastructure are
desperately needed in Africa the continent's death toll is rising.
About 12 billion dollars in Chinese loans were given in
2015 compared with just over 100 million in 2000.
That's according to the China Africa Research Initiative.
And then there are Chinese companies many of which are state owned
sourcing infrastructure projects in cooperation with African governments.
Some do it with financing from the Export Import
Bank of China otherwise known as Exim Bank.
It's a state funded state owned policy lender.
Kenya's SGR between Mombasa Nairobi
was 90 percent funded by such a loan.
I don't think based on the quantity of cargo or the construction costs.
I was custodian of the loan and in addition to the cost of running
the train one way and the other.
It is not possible for the SGR to pay for itself.
I mean we the people cannot pay back the loan obviously we have to.
And the only way we are going to do that
is actually having to suck taxes from other sectors and use that
to services the loan.
A further one and a half billion dollars for the next stage
of the line is largely funded by a loan from Exim Bank.
An extension to Kisumu will cost three point eight
billion dollars and Kenya is now asking China
for half of that as a grant instead of a loan.
What's more to connect the line all the way to Uganda
another four point nine billion dollars may be needed .
Critics of Belt Road have said that these countries are
mortgaging their futures. This is going to lead to a huge
amount of indebtedness which could lead to default which would
then ultimately to China actually controlling vast swathes of these economies .
I don't think that will happen. The evidence spoken about debt
trap diplomacy that it's a sinister move by China to get control
of strategic assets. For example Djibouti is pretty indebted
and they've put up a military base in Djibouti.
Could they get Mombasa port for example if Kenya defaults
on its railway line debts and so on .
It's a very unlikely scenario because the overall trade benefits
and that we will see emerging from this and investment and trade
benefits we see where supercede these .
I am aware that countries often overpay for the infrastructure .
However infrastructure in this case was necessary and I think
overall it would be a benefit to the economy
And infrastructure builders like China Communications Construction companies see
plenty of opportunities to boost their own growth as well as those of African nations.
It is the parent of the company that built and operates the SGR
I think the whole African continent has opportunity for development .
There's a large young workforce but economic growth is slow.
So there are few good job opportunities.
Right now I think they like China back in the 1970s and given China's development
through the years I think Africa will also embrace development opportunities.
But the steady influx of Chinese companies and
workers have fueled accusations that wealth and opportunities
are not being shared with the local community.
I think that definitely if you look at the financing for a lot of these
projects as Chinese banks if you look at the contract areas the
Chinese contractor. So if you're looking for the big ticket so
the person who's receiving the four or five billion dollar
cheque is likely to be in some sort of Chinese entity
And questions about transparency and corruption won't go away .
I think this is a big debate going on whether this Chinese debt
is serviceable or not. And the issue around whether it's
becoming too heavy in indebtedness and therefore ultimately.
It will end up in Chinese hands and there will own the country .
I think what is important here is to note that there should be
no government guarantees for the interest that's being put up .
This should be done on a private sector basis whether come in or
run it operated and finance it and ultimately transfer it at a price
So that they get a good return on as a commercial enterprise.
Look at it both ways. Short term pain for long term gain.
But the Kenyan citizenry knows cutting a very big bad debt
In terms of taxes because we want to pay for the loans
The critic. And it's interesting that still ticking in moth
with a wait and see situation because also unfortunately we have
issues of corruption in the country which really have diverted
some of these resources from what they were meant to be or we
are seeing something that was supposed to be a really big
enterprise or really big project that we hoping.
But it comes out to be a bit substandard than what we expected.
Regarding this. Obviously there are many things that actually happen.
I have not been answered including some of the contacts that have been entered into
the mental costs the public plan on everything is quite clear .
But the real Cross on whether the costing of individual pieces of
equipment and individual construction sites and how it all adds
up is something that should be in question. And I think it's
not as transparent as would be profitable for a piece of
infrastructure that is close to 5 percent of our gross domestic product.
The real question is are those loans used in the right
manner for the right projects that will generate the right type
of revenues for the African country. Again it comes back to the
need for the African countries to develop their own perspectives
holistically not project my project on
what infrastructure they need for what projects what is the best
way to finance these and then to engage with different partners
whether it's the Chinese whether it's the World Bank
on how to go about building these projects .
Coming up forging Africa's future. The past was all about aid
and aid gives us AIDS. It's called Always in Debt Syndrome .
I don't take the easy thing by thinking somebody cheated us.
I don't think so.
I think we asked we made a body but we must take responsibility for his .
Welcome back to Belt Road. China's trade superhighway.
People come to markets like this one in Nairobi to get the best deal that they can.
It's like anywhere else. Ultimately no one is forced to abide
By the same token many people have accused governments
of not haggling hard enough with Beijing.
It's clearly not a two way street. I think it's very very profitable
for the Chinese firms that are involved in actually this.
They want to make very handsome profits on this. No doubt .
But I see. I mean the ethics of all of it notwithstanding. But
I would say well they negotiated the best deal they could get .
And so as Kenyan taxpayers we should be actually asking tough
questions of our own administrators and on our own governance .
How could you in broad daylight make a deal such as this .
Kenyan companies also want to make handsome profits but some sectors are frustrated.
We export quite a lot of our products
agriculture products to the European market. But the Chinese
market is quite is a really untapped. There's some protocols
we're supposed to sign as a government of Kenya so that it can
support our growers to take the products that's there. But it does not done that.
Our manufacturing capacity is not
fulfilled because we are not fully competitive yet and we do
need government intervention to urgently address our competitiveness.
Secondly the
there are no preferential trade agreements also with China .
At the same time both manufacturers and Kenya's leaders see the
increasing numbers of Chinese firms as a positive.
We welcome the Chinese manufacturers to the manufacturing fold .
Manufacturing is part of the big four agenda driven by the government.
And we really need as much investment both local
direct investment as well as foreign direct investment to
onshore into into Kenya and create a very strong manufacturing hub.
President Hu Kenyans as big for agenda aims at boosting
manufacturing to 15 percent of GDP from around about 9 percent by 2022.
Agriculture health and home construction are the other
industries targeted for growth.
Just the extent of manufacturing that we see is
creating thousands of jobs.
Direly required jobs across the continent.
And you're seeing it in increasing numbers.
The innovation that we are seeing the
Chinese bring to Africa.
Sometimes seemingly quite simple
But where they recognize Africa to be a key market.
They are innovating for our markets .
Bidco chairman says local companies can grab opportunities.
If African leaders pull together. VRI is seen by many as being a
one way street. You wanted to be a two way street so you want
access to the Chinese market. You think you will get that.
So I think this is where we must look at Africa becoming more
productive more producing goods that add value add more value to
our products and really become emerging.
And that's the great hope. Will it happen .
I think it's up to us as Africans right to make it happen to
make sure that we do it in the right manner and become
competitive. Today the folly is at intra African trade is at
such a low. We actually putting up more and more barriers
within Africa against each other. And we're allowing China or
America or Europe to come in duty free. And I would dig the
older leadership in Africa to say night because we've talked
about or you you've talked about African Union but it's still
talk. It's called NATO. No action. Talk only.
We've got to get out of that and make it happen .
China's Africa policy has shifted now drawing a clearer line
between official foreign policy and private commerce.
Beijing created a new development agency in April 2018.
It is expected to play a larger part in government strategy as Exim Banks role reduces.
It's one of the criticism China gets a lot which is
that it is offering these loans. Those loans are originated by
the African countries. They are the ones asking for it.
They may have a dream in terms of the nature of the relationship but
I do not think they are trying to shape the future of Africa .
That's not to say aid and lending won't be influenced by
commercial interests interests which some say still have access to resources at their heart.
Chinese companies continue to see an abundance
of opportunity in the continent's rebounding
economy and a green light to raise their presence there under
the banner of the Belt and Road Initiative .
While China sees huge investment opportunities. What about your
average portfolio manager or your retail investor.
Can they also come along for the ride.
If you want to invest directly in this sort of Belt Road initiative that you can do directly
But basically what you're investing is somewhere where perhaps as a
hub for African and international companies.
So as the environment gets easier as say for example the cost of power
comes down then it becomes more easier or more economic to
manufacture goods. So that's the story. So I think for Kenya
and for East Africa as a whole you sort of sell the story of
access not necessarily large minerals or any sort of natural
resources that you get elsewhere in Africa. So I think for us
it's sort of a portal to the rest of Africa. That's the way
that we would look at it.
There is also paying for that.
The thing isn't that ?
I think in the long term you have new towns being opened up.
You have people who can do more commerce who
can ship goods. And also what it's doing is moving perhaps the
industrial heartland of Kenya away from parts of Nairobi to
other parts of the country. So you can manufacture in Naivasha
once the planned industrial hub is set up that and you can then
export straight out to more masses.
And what have complaints Chinese companies is
sweeping up large government contracts in Africa
and White has concerns about challenges to us influence.
I think one thing you got to tell very clearly the Chinese
have a serious advantage in execution. This is where the
Europeans want a head start for the last 50 60 years in Africa
did not do much. The Americans they ignored Africa.
They did not pay attention to it. And when the Chinese came in I think
they've done serious execution on the ground.
They're giving you better infrastructure at lower prices and they've up their game
I think tied aid is gone. Now it's execution.
You can call it economic dominance.
You can go to economic you know colonization colonization.
But Africa needs its restriction now and it needs to be done rapidly.
That's always been the problem
with foreign aid has ended up in people's pockets hasn't it .
Not always.
The past was all about aid and aid gives us
AIDS. Is gold always in debt syndrome .
OK and we don't want to have that. What we want to have now is
make us more competitive ease our doing business.
However we need to make sure that everything has a clear code of ethics .
It's all being done on above board and there's nothing that's
been siphoned off .
The stakes are high for both sides. For China the mouthwatering
potential of new markets they're writ large. Less obviously
those how to tap them and not be seen as the next colonizer .
For the recipients Beijing's initiative offers a multi generational change.
China may well be a partner but it's also a competitor.
Factories like this one can compete with efficient Chinese ones.
Sadly that's not the norm when throwing the gauntlet many have wilted.
The choice ultimately is theirs.
I'm Rishaad Salamat. Thanks for watching .